sie haben gerade gesagt dann bräuchte es
ja neben den stimmzetteln auch stimmen
aus der union die das fordern wir haben
wir gefragt insa aktuell ob sich diese
frage überhaupt noch stellt ob man
darüber noch nachdenkt auch innerhalb
der union und das ist das ergebnis davon
also sollte die union jetzt auf kanzler
söder hat auch kanzlerkandidat markus
söder statt auf amila schützen das erste
mal die zahlen überhaupt über alle
parteien hinweg da sagen 46,7 prozent
der deutschen finden wir gut und dann
haben wir eben nochmal spezifiziert
unionsanhänger gefragt und da fällt das
ergebnis ganz drastisch aus zeigt dass
man bitte kurz das heißt 62 prozent der
anhänger von cdu csu finden das eine
richtig gute idee
ja schon deutliche zahlen aber was soll
ich jetzt das sagen
sozusagen die die messe ist da
eigentlich gesungen
jetzt haben sie gesagt lesen
eigentlich
ja natürlich nach jetzt keine
spitzfindigkeit ja es ist ihm
zugestanden aber da bewegt sich nichts
mehr es hat auch keinen sinn mehr also
normal ist die sache ist jetzt auf den
weg gebracht und jetzt das das hätten
hätten vor monaten hätten da volker
bouffier wolfgang schäuble an andere
sich engagieren müssen jetzt ist die
entscheidung getroffen mir sind damit
find ich tue alles dass das klappt in
die richtung also da an meiner seite
gibt es da keine zweifel daran sie haben
gerade gesagt dann werden sie im
wahlkampf auch immer wieder so den motor
anwerfen das ist sehr bitter wenn
kanzlerkandidaten noch ein motor braucht
der ihn antreibt
also jeder von uns braucht unterstützung
keiner schafft es allein das wäre
umgekehrt bei mir genauso gewesen ich
hätte starke unterstützung von armin
laschet gebraucht er von mir umgekehrt
genauso und es ist auch klar dass wir
keine zwei eigenen einigen zweigen
zwillinge sind ist auch relativ klar wir
beide sind sehr unterschiedliche
persönlichkeiten haben auch
unterschiedliches temperament haben
natürlich an unterschiedlichen politik
stil aber wie immer es ergänzt sich so
ist eine ultra motor sie hat der kern
vom auto also das wissen sie ja viel
besser da in bayern der wenn der nicht
sitzt dann funktioniert halt gar nichts
mehr wenn der motor nicht drin so sie
sagen sie denn der motor von laschet
oder müssen dem den mutter
spiel ohne
die csu wird auch schwer sie dürfen
nicht vergessen wenn sie die gesamt
wahlergebnisse herausrechnen würden also
wenn sie das bayerische ergebnis heraus
rechnen würden dann legt die union ja
heute noch einmal deutlich anders als
bei 23 oder 25 prozent also ist ja ganz
klar genauso wenig wie für die spd
bestimmte bundesländer sehr relevant
sind ist für die union ganz entscheidend
wie man im süden abschneidet darum ist
es da auch relativ wichtig und deswegen
muss man hier auch gemeinsam kämpfen
aber noch einmal die csu war das ja
immer so hat sich franz josef strauß
edmund stoiber nach auch seehofer
verstanden theo waigel viele andere und
da bin ich nur ein ganz brav in der
tradition der csu vorsitz sagt ja noch
was aus wenn der kanzlerkandidat eben
kein motorrad